hello everyone my name is Jordan and I
am joined by Kurt and we both just got
done finished playing Blair Witch the
new first-person horror game developed
by blooper team which is the team that
developed layers of fear layers fear to
an observer so they know how to make a
horror game they've done it plenty of
times before
so Kurt you you and I both got the
chance to play it what are your initial
impressions on your time with the game
what I saw of Blair which I really
thoroughly enjoyed I've played a few
other titles by this company and while I
think what they do is really good in
some places there's other places that I
think kind of fault most specifically
layers if you're - there's something
that's chasing you but it feels like
almost arbitrary in the sense that you
are forced to have to figure a way
around this thing and what Blair which
is doing really interesting or something
that's getting me excited is that it's
adding a few extra tricks in the bag
that make you feel like you're actually
doing something whether that's like you
have a self you have an inventory you
have something more than just having the
run away yeah I would say one of my
favorite aspects of outlast which is a
game very much like Blair Witch and like
layers of fear and whatnot is that it
does a very good job of teaching you
what you're supposed to do to solve a
problem that's coming up instead of just
failing over and over and over again and
the original layers of fear does that
pretty well and layers of - and outlast
- don't do that
very well but Blair which does this
phenomenally well it introduces very
simple concepts at the beginning like
using your flashlight to scare away
ghostly apparitions or listening to
bullet your dog in order to like figure
out where those ghostly apparitions are
before starting to throw all these
things at you at the same time and being
like oh I know what I'm supposed to do
so I'm not just gonna fail outright and
when you do quote-unquote die and like I
have to start over again it doesn't feel
like like you were cheated Blair which
is always trying to help you move
forward whether it's something as simple
as just there's like a light source in a
specific distance at a certain angle so
you know that you're supposed to be
walking in that direction - so
thing as simple as bullets sometimes
wanders off and he comes back with
something or like oh what is this that
you found or you wonder where he's gone
off and you can like click the left
bumper to have him like say like a
bullet where are you in the hill like
bark a few times like oh I should
probably just head in that direction
let's get into that - something that a
lot of these games lack is you're the
accompanying you're usually alone and I
think and I think that's a you know a
good thing in when developing fear and
making you feel alone but we can't
forget that this game has a good boy it
is bullet the bestest the I mean could
be the best boy of 2019 so far we don't
know don't hold me to it but it's good
too
this time around your company with
something that's helping you on your
journey but something that also gives
you weight big allows you to build
attachment to something rather than just
being by yourself wandering through this
environment and something that we kind
of learned while we were there is that
bullet is more than just this companion
who's just with you he's he's somebody
who's going to help you he's also
something you punished like you don't
always have to praise him you could
actually tell him he's doing a bad thing
I say if you think that bullet is
wandering off too often and he's like
dealing with supernatural forces that he
shouldn't be trying to protect you from
you can scold him and depending on
whether you praise him and scold him in
like different scenarios we were told
you'll get different endings to how the
relationship ends between you and bullet
which I'm very curious to see how that
works out because as you said before we
don't typically get horror games where
there's a companion character kind of
there with you and so I'm interested to
see how a changing relationship between
you and another character can influence
how alone are supported you might feel
at the end of the game and something we
haven't even touched on is the camera so
you could mention outlast and how
important the mechanic of a camera is in
outlast but what's being done in Blair
which is that it's an item in the midst
of many items that you have whether it's
your cell phone a walkie talkie a
flashlight but the cameras also use to
solve puzzles so you find tapes around
the world and when you watch these tapes
they're usually video of the area you're
in but what's so fascinating is that a
door may be closed in the reality you're
living in the game but when you watch
the video you
might see a character on the tape go
through that door if you pause the
camera at that certain time it might
open the door in REO say it leaves the
door open in your world and the camera
can be used to solve all these things
out lasses camera just has night vision
which is a very helpful tool for
surviving out less this dark world but
yeah Blair which it's like you have a
night vision mode you have a like sensor
mode that allows you to see ink on the
wall that you can't see with the naked
eye like you said before you can rewind
and fast-forward through tapes to solve
environmental puzzles there's just seems
to be more you can do in Blair which and
even if it's kind of tricking you into
the assumption that's like oh I'm trying
to figure out how to solve this problem
in like one of many different ways like
it's still a game that's very linear
like it's a horror game it's designed to
be solved in a very specific way to put
the scares and the tension in the place
that it has to be but it does it in an
intelligent way that makes you feel like
you are actually solving a puzzle
instead of just wandering around in the
dark looking for the next exit that
you're supposed to find and something
else that's kind of being done in Blair
which that isn't as frequently done in
horror games of this nature is that
Ellis the main character the game also
equally has a presence of voice so he
speaks to himself he speaks to bullets
sometimes I assume it's his
ex-girlfriend just calls him on the
phone and he talks to her as a detective
with a troubled past which has never
been done in a horror game never done
before but Blair was just doing it and
that's fine you know if there's if
there's a method and way to do that and
resurface it in such a way that is
interesting then why not it's let's have
our grizzled grizzled detective with a
troubled past we're talking a lot about
this game and we like it but I think
something that's even more fascinating
or at least adds to something that makes
me more interested in the game is of
course the history of the Blair Witch
franchise this isn't like out lesser
layers of fear which is like a brand new
concept like Blair Witch is building on
a lore that already exists and has
existed for 20 years now that in of
itself is hopefully inviting to a new
audience in the sense that for we for us
20-somethings we are familiar with the
cultural phenomenon that Blair which was
in 1999 I would argue it was like the
thing that
started the found footage movement that
led to paranormal activity and that type
of horror and on top of that internet
marketing it was it was notorious for
making it for using the internet to make
it seem like this was something that
really happened in 1994 in this case of
these these three teenagers these three
kind of aspiring filmmakers with the go
make this documentary about this myth
this witch and what you see is what they
captured only up until a certain point
when it came out when it was announced
at e3 it honestly was a little out of
nowhere was really truly unexpected
because this is something that hasn't
had a real proper video game
representation let alone a good
representation since 1999 we've had two
other movies one of which nobody really
talks about and then a pseudo sequel
remake that came out in 2016 which more
or less clearly didn't have the impact
of the film that in 1999 so why now for
this game well we don't know it's 20
years later actually the twentieth
anniversary but it is interesting like
you know to to pick this franchise up
and try and do something with it that is
a direct almost sequel but prequel to
the 1999 film because this takes place
in 1996 two years after the 1994 case of
Blair Witch but all said and done for
what it's worth in kind of the off took
surprise I think I myself at least had
with the announcement of this game I'm
really kind of excited and interested to
see what this is gonna be in late August
when it comes out
you